you always play invariable you play very
nice people
well I think I think for a lot of price
yes it can vary not so much in Fargo but
a lot of times I think when you first
got known in America people think of you
as this very nice guy
are you that guy in real life sometimes
yes and sometimes not that guy
yeah be a terrible life to be nice all
the time
wouldn't it be boring and it'd be
one-dimensional and it wouldn't be true
because some things in life make you
excessively angry and full of rage I get
this I get the sense that that's
happening to you right now this is one
of those yeah you're just seeing so
angry be on the show
I blame Neil and not myself why would I
just say yeah I just say Fargo your role
in that was just amazing thank you very
much really great yeah
all right so this is sort of my job okay
can I just be Pham it these questions in
admit you're jealous you don't have it
getting the microphone I don't
understand what's happening right here
and losing control so sensitive I'm
sorry Kevin are their knowledge eyes for
Conan I'm under a lot of pressure are
you sort of his not carer but his helper
in some ways I cannot give him enough
help that he needs
you can kevin oíhara and we're talking
so you got you started me I saw England
yeah of London nice
sorry he's getting I got a lager you
getting back get back he's you know I
will I want to pick up on something
Kevin said all joking aside which is he
brought up Fargo you did a brilliant
American accent thank you in Fargo and I
think people that hadn't known your
other work didn't know that you were
from England we assumed oh this this
actor is is thoroughly American hmm how
hard is it to do mmm an authentic
American accent well I think you need to
attend to the details so I think you can
you're in trouble if you get lazy and
think I can do that I can do that and
then don't keep the details up so I
think it's but for me if I'm doing an
accent that's very different to my own I
will stay in that accent all day oh I'm
saying it the whole time that you're
shooting even if there's a break and
it's time to eat your you'll still stay
in it I won't stay in character it's not
like I demand you call me you know the
character name I'm sorry Martin but I'm
just Martin with whatever accent is so
I'll just be saying whatever I would
normally say but just in that accent
because I thought it's too difficult to
go from this to Minnesota or Glasgow or
whether you know it yes it's it's a
muscle you know it's a physical act you
know that putting on an accent to keep
it going my question is then what do you
think about I always am amazed and I
think British actors from the UK are so
well trained they can do that they can
do an American accent so authentically
yeah sometimes I think Americans try to
do a British accent it doesn't go as
well I think genuinely in in a few cases
I think it's really good and then but
the rule I'm gonna say I'm gonna say the
rule is Americans when we do a British
accent we we don't even know no we're
just doing some random stab at something
I mean Kevin your British accents
terrible well I do beetle accents ok
talk like John Levin
it's more Liverpool you know who does
that no one talks that way not even the
Beatles II and you looking at you then
no one does that they do that to any
living Beatle and they'll hit you in the
face
sure yeah you know who what Britt did a
great English accent undetectable well
American accent it was Alec Baldwin you
don't know that he's British at all no I
mean fooled me and he sticks with it all
the time yeah yeah you were in the black
pants what's your English accent like
it's not good well I've talked about
this before but I grew up finds the
over-the-top I grew up loving as a kid
growing up Mary Poppins so I learned
mine from Dick Van Dyke it's the best
place to learn who famously everyone in
Britain and talked to Dick Van Dyke
about this he said some guy told me to
do that and it turned out later on he
wasn't from England either he totally
got screwed but mars-like alo
because that requires a certain volume
yes
demand that requires a certain sake
don't think part is it it implies that
everyone in England is hard of hearing
no but when I was a kid I was convinced
I had an amazing British accent and I
would just basically what was convincing
you because it wasn't that was I mean
I'm not trying to insult but were you
doing other English accents that good
not that one that was it that one it was
that one I would do it in the mirror and
then I would give myself major awards
for you know three major invisible
awards yes I was quite captivated with
my own performance say something else
now that isn't about chimneys or it's a
different context say oh this is what a
lovely day is today I'm happy to be
alive what a lovely day it is to die oh
so happy to be alive I am
you can't resist it you can't resist it
you have to do this yeah you have to do
this your pimp your pocket I wear light
wear cuz you'll notice that's how I
walked on yes it's true you didn't see
but backstage you were walking around
with you in your lamb before yeah me
Kenneth Branagh and if it's L became on
our yeah
you